all right welcome to Hannity we begin
tonight with many Fox news alerts buckle
up an unbelievable day a lot of news to
cover tonight so many breaking stories
we'll get it all in including details
from the FISA abuse report we had a
train wreck press conference from Nancy
Pelosi that left her seething with rage
we've got that tape also more fallout
from yesterday's disaster and kangaroo
court for the Democrats and nutty Nadler
but first with the twenty20 election and
only 334 days you have the power I do
have hope I do have optimism because the
radical far-left socialist Democratic
Party is now in shambles tonight from
top to bottom that because it's filled
with so-called elites who are totally
detached from reality but they think
they are better they're smarter they're
more capable than all of us well as
Peter struck said we smelly Trump
Walmart shopper voters Obama said
remember they were bitter we cling to
our God yeah we do
we believe in the Second Amendment true
our Bible absolutely and our religion
Hillary Clinton called us irredeemable
deplorable z' well nutty Jerry Nadler
nutty Nadler hauled in three ivory tower
radical antitrump
as far left as you can go college
professors to educate we the uninformed
masses on the virtues of impeachment
even one professor that wanted Trump and
Peach for tweeting the words fake and
news fake news and today during this
disastrous Town Hall Wow couldn't
believe this a very agitated Joe
three-on-three 300 stood he went off on
an 83 year old voter an unhinge rant he
called the guy fat and then denied it
claimed he's a damn liar belittled this
guy suggesting that the man had a low IQ
and then he challenged him to a push-up
contest in competition so why did
Joe snap because this voter dared to
politely ask a question about zero
experience hunter the millions of
dollars he's making sitting on a board
of the corrupt Ukrainian oil and gas
giant Purisima Holdings all while his
father then the Vice President of the
United States served
as the Obama administration's point
person on all things Ukraine you have to
watch as you watch fighting viciously
attack this voter for asking well what
the media mob should be asking a very
important question you're selling access
to the president the reason I'm running
is because I've been around and you want
to check my shape on let's do push-ups
together man let's do that's wrong let's
do whatever you wanna do no one has said
my son has done anything wrong and I did
not in any occasion and no one has ever
said you said I set up my son to work in
an oil company didn't work she said I'm
sure when straitjacket
here's the deal here's the deal
Natsuki looks like you don't have your
back
yeah man one of a push-up contest Jack
okay how does this guy house even a
candidate voters be warned you asked Joe
303 303 Lee Crane scandal it might
challenge you to a duel or maybe a
push-up contest and call you fat insult
your intelligence fly off the handle
lose it but he definitely won't answer
your question and if the corrupt media
mob ever gets their way he'll never have
to answer for his very real abuse of
power we all know the evidence is there
creepy crazy Uncle Joe was right about
one thing you're not going to hear about
this on MSD and C or fake news CNN or
anywhere else in the mob media because
they are state-run liberal TV in fact
during a press conference following his
meltdown Biden wasn't once challenged as
he continued to trash this poor guy 83
years old over and over again take a
look I don't lose my temper what I
wanted to do is shut this down you saw
the reaction all the people here
you saw the response and so I mean it
was what what was that what did Baba
them is he wouldn't give him the
microphone back and why didn't we kind
of pulled it away and what I wanted to
make clear to him was that that you know
his if he gets more out of control this
is not appropriate behavior at all wait
you said no let him go
there it is former vice president
calling a an 83 year old guy stranger
fat a damn liar insulting his
intelligence at the same Town Hall the
same one Biden said he was in Ohio he
was in Iowa he also claimed he was the
vice president in 1976 can't pick this
up but sure Joe that voter he's the one
out of control
this is not a good look for Uncle Joe or
the Democratic Party he's starting to
crack voters are now understanding the
incontrovertible truth the overwhelming
evidence because in 2014
Vice President Biden was appointed as
the
country's point person for Ukraine short
time later zero experience hunter was
hired to serve on the board of Maurice
for Holdings a corrupt oil and gas giant
he was paid millions of millions of
dollars zero experience zero experience
in gas zero experience at energy zero
experience in Ukraine he's old for three
instead of experience Hunter was
peddling access as it turns out it was a
great investment for parisa because in
hunter Biden and his company they faced
a corruption investigation by Ukraine's
top prosecutor who came to the rescue
daddy Joe Biden the vice president
demanding a prosecutor and Ukraine be
fired why would that ever happen Joe
Biden actually leveraged and brags about
leveraging a billion US tax dollars in
aid to get a prosecutor in Ukraine fired
why because he was told by the New York
Times and others that they that
prosecutor was investigating his zero
experience son that's being paid
millions remember Vice President Biden
bragged told the president of Ukraine
I'm getting on a plane in six hours all
right you're not getting a billion
dollars you're not gonna get it you have
six hours fire the prosecutor I'll give
you the billion dollars son of a B they
fired the prosecutor and while hunters
in the clear that is a quid and a pro
and a quote by Joe could you imagine the
reaction if this was Don Jr Eric Trump o
or thirteen-year-old bear and Trump a
teenager that's how low the Democrats
have sunk they go after a teenager
that's how repulsive they now are
imagine if it was Trump bragging well
you're not getting it unless you fire
the prosecutor that was Don junior zero
experience being paid millions no I
would be in jail today let's be honest
about this
and the mob and the media is no credible
credibility ever this is he got to take
this in breath taking hypocrisy and
corruption they the mob media that is
state-run democratic TV and now breaking
this week a judges ruled hunter Biden
he's gonna have to turn over his
financial files so soon we might know
exactly how much he actually made from
verismo and oh yeah what about how much
was in the I never got
penny from China how much equity did he
get in that deal with the Bank of China
that his lawyers had well he hasn't
cashed his equity yet he has I think the
technically got in a penny yet and get
this if Democrats are actually able to
pass impeachment in the house the
Biden's will likely now be called to
testify during the republican-controlled
Senate trial this is going to be
must-see TV but Joe 303 300 was telling
reporters he's not going to appear
voluntarily
that's because quid pro quo Joe has a
lot to hide and also breaking tonight
this a big story in The Wall Street
Journal by their editorial board shifts
broad definition of bribery would mean
that Joe could also easily be impeached
louie gohmert
my radio show today said I would
actually be a real insurance policy